awesome breaking news from overnight one  person is dead following a shooting in  the South Valley this just before 11  o'clock last night around Warm Springs  in Bermuda Metro Police responding to  reports of a man down by the side of the  road when they got there they did find a  man in his 50s with multiple gunshot  wounds  we don't know what led up or the motives  leading up to the shooting I anticipate  that we'll be out here the next few  hours the only road closure that we have  right now is on Placid Street after  Lieutenant Jason Johansen says they  think the victim lived in the area if  you have any information on the shooting  you're asked to call the homicide  division or Crime Stoppers